good afternoon i am assistant sheriff
lozaro chavez and i am here to brief you
on additional details as we know them
today about the officer-involved
shooting that occurred on tuesday
november 16 2000
21.
this officer involved this is officer
involved shooting number nine for 2021.
uh non-fatal number four
the same time last year this was we were
at ois number 17 and non-fatal number
eight
the officers involved our first officer
is jeffrey burr he's 34 years old and
has been with lvmpd since 2009. in this
incident officer burr was armed with a
glock 19 i'm sorry a glock 17 nine
millimeter handgun equipped with a
tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired 13
rounds during the incident
the second officer is demario simmons
he's 29 years old and has been with
lvmpd since 2021.
in this incident
officer simmons was armed with a glock
17
nine millimeter and was also equipped
with the tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired six
rounds
during the incident
both officers are assigned to the
community policing division at northeast
area command
the suspect is identified as
tavion davidson he's a 25 year old male
5 8 178 pounds he is pictured to my left
on the screen
in this incident davidson was armed with
a semi-automatic springfield hellcat
nine-millimeter handgun
the investigation revealed revealed that
he fired one round at our officers
during this incident
and there's also a photo on the screen
of the firearm that he was carrying
davidson's charges
include a tent murderer on a police
officer two counts
shooting into an occupied structure
prohibited person in possession of a
firearm and carrying a concealed
weapon
the details
are as follows
on tuesday november 16 2021
lvmpd dispatch center received a call
from a mobile home park reporting two
suspicious males
who were walking through the complex
and one of them was armed with a handgun
the male with the firearm was later i
dave identified as tavion davidson
officer burr and simmons arrived at the
mobile home park observed davidson
walking towards the front of the
entrance of the complex
officer burr
engaged davidson in a conversation and
eventually asked him to face a parked
car in order to conduct a weapons pat
down
instead of complying with the officer's
request davidson ran away
from both officers
both officers
gave chase and officer burr observed
davidson pull a firearm
as he was running away
officer burr told davidson several times
to drop the gun but davidson ignored
those commands and continued to run
during the foot pursuit davidson stopped
and turned towards
officer burr and fired one round at him
both officers returned i'm sorry both
officer burr and simmons returned fire
striking davidson
davidson continued to flee from the
officers and jumped a small chain-link
fence at which point he fell to the
ground and surrendered
officers arrived on scene
at which time davidson was taken into
custody without further incident
davidson was provided first aid
by the officers until paramedics arrived
at the scene
he was then transported to umc trauma
and treated for non-life-threatening
injuries
davidson has been booked in abstentia
for the aforementioned charges
i will now show you two
body worn camera videos of the
officer-involved shooting
where are you heading to
where you headed to
which one's your house
the first one
can i talk to you for a minute come on
over here
what's that
what's that
all right come on over here face the car
let me make sure you don't have any
weapons
[Applause]
444 shots fired he's running northbound
you'll see in this slow down version of
the suspect crouching down
and firing at the officer
there's a little better picture of it
this is a video from the second officer
[Applause]
again this one you can see as
the suspect runs away still has a
firearm in his hand
okay this concludes the briefing are
there any questions about how far was
the suspect from the officer at the time
uh i think that was about 24-25 feet
yes he fired one round in that still
picture that shows him in the low ready
position and he's firing at the officer
you can actually see the smoke from the
firearm as he shot at the officer
yes sir
good question yes the uh the round that
was fired
uh by the suspect actually struck a
trailer that's directly behind the
officer and there was a person inside
what about the ones that were
behind the subject
was behind the suspect there was some a
trash can and i think an eve at the very
top of the trailer up there that was
struck
yes after the shooting this is him
running away after the shooting
the second mail we did arrest a second
person but we still are not
completely sure if he was the one that
was uh involved in this event we're
still in the process of
interviewing witnesses and
he's not being cooperative the
non-life-threatening injuries were they
due to the fall
the non-life-threatening injuries were
from gunshots that he received yesterday
yes mr davidson was connected to trailer
number one which was uh nearest the
entrance to the park
uh we'll release that information at the
conclusion of the interview here and
you'll all be provided with with that
suspicious activity you didn't live in
that
did you get details
yes the suspicious activity was that the
male was walking through the complex
holding a firearm
so this is an extraordinary display of
bravery by our officers and i want to
make sure we pointed that out
unfortunately we continue to deal with
this sort of violence against police
officers across the country and
certainly here in las vegas
and we were able to apprehend the
suspect safely
before he was able to hurt anybody in
the complex so thank you all for your
time and if you have any other questions
you can contact the cio